[Music]
now and then
i get to meet someone who absolutely
inspires me
keelan blackwell is that person he grew
up in an affluent neighborhood
in wisconsin set on the path to
go to college and get a good career but
he decided to leave it all
to follow his own path one driven by
faith and conviction
one driven by a desire to serve
his story is filled with ups and downs
trials and tribulations
he ended up homeless at one point but
always driven by this faith he
never gave up his story is absolutely
inspiring he turned his life around
and became a social entrepreneur now
giving back to the very community
that helped lift him up his story
and he are absolutely magical
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
keelan so good to see you thanks for
joining me
the reason i wanted to talk to you
is i'm kind of in awe of some of the
life decisions you've made
to be honest you made decisions to give
back to your community to live a life of
service which i admire and love
but you have done so with this intense
conviction
to go and live in the world that you
work in
which is not the world that you grew up
in that's correct yep
just give me a little bit of background
about how you grew up where you grew up
and
how and why you find yourself where you
are today
yeah so i grew up in madison wisconsin
i'm a proud wisconsin badger
you know my parents had like both really
good jobs uh
you know i grew up upper middle class i
didn't want for anything i had a very
very good childhood yeah where i am now
i'm in inglewood on the south side of
chicago so it's like really the
antithesis of what my experience was
growing up you know but like while i was
a child my dad
uh he was the first one to really
instill in me this idea of community
service you know because
i was uh getting a little too big for my
britches as a kid you know how it is
when you're that preteen teenager phase
you [ __ ] challenge your
your parents and you know particularly
my dad and i just started uh you know
telling him hey you know like i'm i'm
some hot stuff so i don't need you
you know i felt like i was grown before
i was grown
and he felt like he needed to knock me
down a few pegs and he was like you know
what keelan
i think it's time for you to understand
that the world's bigger than just
you um so what he did is he actually had
me
volunteer at a community center where
there had a lot of refugees from
southeast asia it's like at that time
you know there's like a lot of refugees
from the vietnam war this is like
you know late 90s early 2000s it was
like me in middle school
through that experience you know i
really began to see that oh not everyone
has what i have because i just sort of
had this assumption as a kid like most
people do that oh everyone must be going
through
what i'm going through so i would say
like that was like the first
maybe a flexion point in my life where i
began to realize that i
had a pretty privileged upbringing and
then from there i just sort of got
hooked so
you know at first my dad intended it to
be more of a punishment
but then like the following summer i
voluntarily said hey you know
actually i'll go back there you know
because i was like i had so many good
experiences
i'm like working with these families i'm
hearing their stories and it just really
like convicted my heart oh there's more
to this world than just
being this young hot shot so yeah that's
pretty much like i would say like
the the impetus of what got me on this
road and then you know from there it's
just been pretty much
me following my faith i think i told you
before like i'm a christian
so that just really just added coals to
the fire
really just this conviction that i need
to live my life in such a way where i
need to give back to
mankind into the world so let me take a
step back for a second
can you tell me one of the specific
stories that you experienced with the
families
from vietnam that you were working with
when you were in middle school that
really
set you on this course yeah i'm 100
transparent
okay so hopefully it's a no judgment
zone so no judgment zone
[Laughter]
so you know like as a kid i would say i
was like racist against like
you know immigrants and agents in
particular because you know like madison
at that time was
mostly why you know my idea of like
americans and culture was more this
black white dynamic
so you know when you start having like
this influx of you know southeast asians
you know i didn't really you know i
don't know their language their customs
you know i feel like their knee-jerk
reactions fear right so
one things i would do as a kid is you
know like there's like a hill that would
like
look down on where the uh uh you know
the community center was
and me and my friends were like well
they were just like you know toss rocks
at like uh the people there
so you know when i was like volunteering
i began to
get to know these people and you know
one of the kids basically talked about
how like one of those rocks hit him
and uh you know he's just saying like
hey you know my family moved here they
kind of went through the whole or
explained to me this ordeal of how they
had escaped out of vietnam
it was like this really hellish
experience they didn't know where
they're gonna end up it's not like they
were looking to come to us
there was like a few different options
they didn't know what wisconsin was they
know what madison was i mean
they're just trying to like save their
life right and that just really touch
because i'm like hey here i am
throwing rocks into basically assaulting
these people who i don't know
they're just human beings like me you
know they're just looking for a better
life i would say
you know make me feel bad is probably an
understatement yeah
it's just a memory that i just don't
forget and it's something
you know where i just like thank god
that he's given me enough grace
to kind of continue to live the life
that i have and really try to like do my
best to
you know really be understanding and
seek compassion first right because
you don't know how you're hurting people
when you succumb to hate and prejudice
and racism
yeah and so you went back the following
year yeah
and was that experience more of the same
different
because clearly you're on a path and
there's a momentum here
so i'm interested in what happened in
the following year but even how it
affected you when you went back to
school
yes like the second year is interesting
because it was more about
building the relationships that got
established that previous summer so i
felt like that second year we began to
relate
you know more on a peer basis because
that first year i kind of went in and
then i kind of came in this idea of like
okay i'm here to help you my dad's
telling me to do this
you know i didn't really look at it as
like this is something we're doing
together that second year
it became more of like okay we're doing
this together and i kind of began to
look at it as hey these
people have something to teach me you
know so my posture was totally different
and i began to learn a lot about among
people and cambodians and laotians
interestingly enough like as i got into
high school you know i became
more accepted in that community you know
i was like playing basketball with a lot
of those guys
my first girlfriend was hmong i really
began to become very immersed
in sort of that southeast asian
community the thing i think like really
got me was just like the love they
showed me knowing
you know some of the acts that i did
that i'm not proud of but the fact that
they're willing to forgive me for that
and accept me for who i am and really
take me in
to this day like i have close friends
who are cambodian and hmong
so i just look at like man like these
people like really
contributed to a part of my life my
personality
and it's all because i basically took
that step outside my comfort zone right
i took
that step outside my box which is i
think gonna be a theme
which is this idea of stepping outside
your comfort zone i still need to get
you to where you are today
which is outside your comfort zone
yes that's 100 true no i look back on my
my journey to where i am today you know
it's like it's like the little building
blocks right it's like these little
things that
you didn't necessarily think would lead
to somewhere yeah but like it kind of
just built up over time it just built
this momentum
where eventually it leads me to where i
am today so you grew up upper middle
class
you had every opportunity afforded to
you and now you live in one of the most
dangerous neighborhoods in one of the
most dangerous cities
in the country right how does that
happen
i mean a lot happened in between there
but i would say the biggest thing is i
had to like
really get to a place in my life where i
got over myself yeah
and it's this whole idea that you know
we kind of like hold tightly onto
the life that we think we should be
living but it's actually may not
necessarily be the best path for us
so if you're willing to like give that
up then you can basically find a
superior life right
in service and giving and that kind of
thing and i would say
the rubber met the road in like 2011.
you know i just got the peace corps i
was like living with my parents
trying to get reacclimated to living in
the united states again after i was like
in thailand for two years
and you know i just really i had a
quarter life crisis to be honest with
you
and i was just thinking like hey what am
i gonna do with my life right you know i
began to think like okay
moving forward who should i really be
trying to like help and
particularly black people right because
up until this point
i've never really lived in a black
community you know like madison's mostly
a white community
then i was in the peace corps you know i
was in thailand obviously that's asian
i went to university of
wisconsin-madison which is like 90 white
so you know all this time i really was
disconnected from my own people
i'm like seeing and hearing about you
know of course like you know the hood
and you know the plight of
african-americans in this country
and i just really felt like okay you
know what i've been
giving of myself to all these other
people groups but what about my own
people right
and that's really when i began to make a
conscious decision that from that day
forward
i will be very intentional about
reconnecting with my own roots
had you experienced racism yourself
because you said you you
you know you you uncomfortably admit
that you you
you had racist sentence abilities as a
young kid had you experienced racism in
in these predominantly white
neighborhoods white universities
even going even going to thailand uh is
that trick question
because uh yes i mean
go on
because there's an irony to it right
right i mean yeah so i have experienced
you know my fair share racism
particularly in school
yeah and you're right there's an irony
to it that's not lost on me
yeah which i think has softened my heart
in a way
once they soften my heart mean like this
ideal that you know racism
doesn't define you from my perspective
right you know i look at it as more of
i don't know if you want to take a
disease or whatever else you want to
call it blood it's just something that
someone can succumb to
because of ignorance because of maybe
you're not happy with your lot in life i
mean there's a million reasons why
you could succumb to it and it's not
exclusive to just white people right
you know like i said i participate in
myself
you know if it's very easy these days to
like really have like a chip on your
shoulder and
focus on the ways you've been hurt right
focus on the ways you've been slighted
but we never really think about the ways
we slight other people
the ways we hurt other people right you
know we always want grace we always want
to pass on that
and i've been like you know what god's
using me today despite the fact that
i did some things in my life that i'm
very ashamed of and i'm not proud of
so you know who am i to basically say
hey because you're white
and you did x y z to me you know i'm
gonna hold that against you forever you
know i know that's a very
easy thing for a lot of people to hear
you know that's like that's that's a
strong conviction for me that you know
like we do need to live our lives in a
way
where we have grace and forgiveness and
understand that like hey you know what
like you don't know
people's full story like i guarantee you
before you got on this call with me
you know you didn't know that i threw
rocks at asian kids you know what i mean
like you never
guessed that and i could have totally
got by with this every without admitting
that right
but you know it's just important to me
for people understand like hey
you know i'm flawed just like anybody
else but
you know there's a grace that god has
for you know my life
and other people so that you can still
be used because i feel like there's
a hope piece to it that gets lost when
you begin to like really judge people
for their worst moments
what i find so interesting about your
story is this recurring theme of
narrative
you know where we have a narrative of
what our lives are supposed to be
i'm supposed to go to college i'm
supposed to get this kind of job i'm
supposed to live in this neighborhood
and you talked about letting go of that
story
right and letting go of that narrative
of what i quote unquote
should be doing right right based on
parental pressure societal pressure or
made-up pressure
right and i think we've all had that
we've all
found ourselves in a path that we didn't
want to be on but this is the path i'm
supposed to be on
and your ability to let go of that
narrative which opened a whole new set
of opportunities and experiences for you
right and this idea of narrative
that somebody who did an act is
i'm going to judge their character based
on the act that they performed
rather than saying maybe they succumbed
to something because again there's a
narrative there's
self-loathing or displeasure with my lot
in life or
maybe i learned the wrong lessons as a
kid like who knows there's a long list
that would cause someone to act in these
what we consider horrible ways
right and the ability for you not only
to let go of your own narrative
that opened up a whole new path for you
a path of conviction
rather than you know sort of predestiny
i guess
you know predestined to live an unhappy
life
[Laughter]
this idea that and then also your
ability to let
to recognize that you don't understand
somebody else's narrative
right to be to to work and it's not easy
to be free of judgment
it's much easier to judge yeah i
definitely think
like that definitely created like a
great crisis of
identity and like really that crisis i
think started in thailand
this is my first time overseas i've
never been overseas you know knowing my
family really been overseas
and my whole context has been identified
as an african-american within the united
states
so when i went to thailand there's
totally different there's more about
your nationality right
so as an american i'm like top of the
totem pole so ideals like who am
i right you know i got good grades in
school i went to college
i'm supposed to get a good job i'm
supposed to get married you know sort of
predetermined narrative that
you know really was fostered upon you if
you can't stop and think about it you
don't really question it
so like that really kind of gave me a
space when i was entitled to begin to
think about
well who am i and why did i buy into
this narrative is this really who i
am is this something i really want to be
and that was a very very difficult
process because you know you really have
to
break yourself down at that point in
order for you to be able to build
yourself
up in a way where it's really scary
because the thing about
the you know the narrative you're
talking about is like there's safety in
it oh i know
who i'm supposed to be i know the
direction supposed to go because
everyone else is doing it
right it's a herd mentality thing but
when you basically decide to book that
trend
and now it's like hey i have to
basically break down who i am inside
to build myself up we know where am i
going to live what's my job going to
look like
right so that was the most scary part
you know i made a promise to myself that
you know regardless of whatever
path i made i wasn't going to quit so i
was like i'm going to see this through
compel or high water if i ended up
homeless i end up homeless
if i end up flying i end up flying but
what was more important to me
was being true to myself and i think
that more people
if they have that courage to really just
face themselves and break themselves
down and be honest about that
just build themselves up again you know
we'll have a much more
peaceful and prosperous world you're
offering something that is
damn near impossible to do i mean let's
break this down
you're proposing to instead of following
the predetermined path of quote-unquote
certainty
even if it leads to your unhappiness to
take a
risk to get off that path to follow your
true joy your true conviction
even if the outcome is homelessness
right yep most people
will say i'm i'm gonna stay on this
unhappy
unfulfilled path right right right i'll
take this certainty
versus that risk right so
where did the courage come from i mean
this is basically what you're talking
about is an entrepreneurial venture but
with your life
yes that's exactly you know because when
somebody goes on an entrepreneurial
venture they could become a
multi-millionaire or they can end up
bankrupt or something
somewhere in between and so you're
taking an entrepreneurial risk but with
your life which is
even scarier than an entrepreneurial
risk with your career
right and you know and in full in full
disclosure i was homeless i was hungry
i mean i remember when i first came to
chicago you know i basically sold
everything that i had i moved here
and it was like hey look this is my
conviction i feel like this is what god
is asking me to do and i had nothing
and i when i say nothing i mean
literally nothing like my first place i
just had
a one-month lease in this flooded
basement because i only had a couple
hundred dollars to my name
and then after that i was basically just
living on the generosity of other people
and that was both like humbling and
scary
i was like you know god why'd you bring
me here to just to fail
um and yeah like it was it was
emotionally
distraught because like all i knew was
comfort right yeah
so to basically it's one thing to be
poor and to go through that
because circumstances like force you to
it's another thing for you to
voluntarily go through that right and
then
stick with it but once again i made that
commitment that i'm not gonna quit
so even though the temptation to
basically call my parents at that time
and say hey
i'm struggling please bail me out you
know because i had that i had that get
out jail card that most people didn't
have
right i could have easily at any moment
go back to that life
but i was like you know what i'm going
to commit myself to this path
i mean when i look back on it i really
just think i was curious
that's why i know like hey if i stick
this thing out what's gonna happen
right and i remember like thinking to
myself okay you know like in those
moments there are many moments i want to
give up trust me
uh but in those moments when i wanted to
give up i remember thinking to myself
okay
when i'm like old and gray on my
deathbed
am i gonna look back on my life and have
this massive regret
that i gave up only a couple years into
a hardship
and not really you know sort of seeing
it through and seeing hey what would
have happened if i stuck it out
and just that you know persistent
thought in my head
kept me going through those hard days
you talked about living off the
generosity of others can you tell me
the name of someone who without this
person you probably wouldn't have made
it through you probably would have quit
so there's this person named michelle
michelle muniz michelle was someone who
i met
at the church um that i was going to
hear in chicago i didn't know we're like
total stranger right they didn't know me
from adam
but she saw that i was struggling i mean
had clothes with holes in them the whole
nine yards
she like sort of struck up a
conversation with me one day trying to
get to know me
kind of get on my situation i feel like
i'm new to chicago that kind of deal
and when i told her that like hey yeah
like i only got a few more days in my
place and then
after that i got nowhere to go she was
like well hey you know what let me call
my sister because i think she may have a
room
maybe you could crash there for a few
weeks until you get yourself on your
feet and she did that like you know her
sister elena
let me stay at her place for a few weeks
and that was a godsend
because it did give me like a little
stability in this chaotic situation
and then when i was able to upgrade to
renting a room more than just on a
month-to-month basis
i still was like having a hard time with
food and clothes and that kind of deal
so michelle like offered to like you
know buy me groceries you know she like
take me to like different puerto rican
restaurants
um but she really was like one of those
uh angels in those early days that
kind of came out of nowhere but she just
had uncommon generosity for whatever
reason i'm even to this day
i don't know what moved her to help me
out but i mean i'm definitely thankful
for it
i think this is so important which is
it's one thing to take the risk
what has to be stressed here is you
didn't do this alone right
though you were lonely at times you
didn't do this alone
and your courage wasn't solely internal
conviction
but rather the love of others and the
uncommon generosity of others
in some way shape or form fueled your
conviction is that a
is that fair yes that's very astute
observation
because like the thing is when you have
people who show that kind of generosity
to you it's very important right
i literally just got done crying to god
and crying in my bed
you know here i am i meet michelle a day
or two after that
it was just enough of a spark to keep me
going to make me feel like i didn't make
the wrong decision
to make me feel like hey you know what
like i can live to fight another day
and frankly what you're saying like i'm
not in this by myself that there's
other people who are looking at my
struggles who see me
and who are willing to help and like
yeah this definitely at least you know
my life is definitely not a solo sport
you know what i mean there's been
many michelle's along the way i mean she
just stands out because she kind of came
at a time that
was very critical you know to me in the
early days because when you start out's
always the most hardest right
i want to underscore what you just said
you said something very profound
which is life is not a solo sport yes
which is i think an incredibly profound
thing because we all think of ourselves
as individuals
trying to make it in life or make a life
for ourselves
but the reality is it's not a solo sport
it's my life your life
our lives as individuals is actually a
team sport right
yes exactly and you know the thing about
that you don't you never know who's on
your team
and you're never right i didn't know
michelle was on my team yeah and then
there were people who i thought were on
my team who weren't on my team
you know so so yeah and that's where
like it's just been
like really cool we kind of talk about
this idea of humanity and people
supporting you
and then of course you want to pay it
forward you know like that's what really
helps me to continue to live the life
that i'm living because i remember those
strangers who helped me along the way
so i'm like who am i not to help a
stranger because they helped me out
i think you may have offered the best
definition of faith i've ever heard
[Laughter]
which is that you're on a team and you
don't know who's on your team
and we talk about certainty we think
that the people who we can rely on
will be there for us but we don't really
know until it's tested
we create this narrative it's the exact
same thought process that is
this is the life i have to live it's
this choice of certainty even though
it's really uncertain
that's the irony what you traded as one
kind of uncertainty for another kind of
uncertainty they're both exactly the
same except one has a
a narrative which is a fiction and the
other one was literally an unknown
yes so you traded a fiction for an
unknown
the the life you chose is actually the
same and
faith is accepting that i am on a team
and i don't know who my teammates are
and the faith that the team will be
there to support me even though i don't
know who they are when they're going to
show up
which is kind of amazing i'm gonna steal
that even though i said it
but you know now that you've kind of uh
packaged it
[Laughter]
that's totally not what i was thinking
but you're 100 correct on that yes like
faith is literally being on team but not
knowing who's on your team that's 100
true
yeah so i have to ask there's all this
build up
how did you get to do what you're doing
now you
now grow flowers in the inner city
yes no one expected to hear that
yes i am the flower man that is 100
so get to how you got to what you're
doing now i'm having a lot of fun you
know i like talking to
simon the feeling's mutual caitlyn
but yes once i really started to get
established here and really get
comfortable with sort of the unknown and
i like the way you
store a couch that day yes i basically
traded in a perceived
fictional certainty for this unknown and
once i got more comfortable with that
then i began to realize oh there's a lot
of power with this right like
it started to feel like a game like
who's gonna come out the woodwork that's
gonna
open up some door who's going to help me
out well you have more freedom right
because you don't actually have to force
your life to obey the fiction
yeah to obey the preconceived path
everybody has the same freedom right
but you actually created a mechanism
that allowed you to take a step
off the fiction and actually appreciate
all the opportunities
and relationships and generosities that
actually
were in front of you ironically that are
actually in front of everyone
and that's true you know and the thing
is like what i'm doing anybody can do
yeah it's literally just like the way
you perceive your life and that's where
the power really came from is
i felt liberated like for the first time
in my life i'm like oh i'm free
i mean you look on the surface and i
didn't look free because you know i look
broke and i was broke
but mentally and psychologically and
emotionally spiritually i felt like
there was nothing that hindered me
so then when that happens taking risk
becomes a lot easier
right so when you talk about how you go
from you know sort of being this like
you know bummy guy
just kind of barely making it to all of
a sudden having this prosperous flower
business
is essentially because my mindset
changed that hey i'm just gonna continue
to explore
i'm gonna continue to get more curious
and then one day
i find myself starting eco house this is
like 2014.
because i find myself like a tutoring
here at a school in
inglewood here on the south side i get
more connected with
people in the community and one of the
things that people are saying as i'm
like getting to know them is
hey you know what kelan if you really
want to help jobs
you know and but not just like any kind
of jobs but jobs that are here
here in our community that are
accessible i think that's a thing that
a lot of people don't recognize which is
poor people don't need money poor people
need jobs
yes i think a lot of people
underestimate that
jobs more about just making a check
right there's a dignity to creating
something
that adds value to other people yeah
like people want to give
you know what i mean and if you work
your job you work it well like you're
giving you're enhancing you know your
communities
so what is ecohouse so eco house is a
organization
that has a mission of using
sustainability to alleviate
inner city poverty and we do that by
taking over vacant lots
and converting them into these off-grid
100 sustainable flower farms
that create jobs for at-risk young
people so we work with a lot of gang
bangers
a lot of kids who are coming out the
system a lot of kids who basically are
living on the margins or in extreme
poverty
you know but the whole idea is to
essentially induce
bottom-up economic growth in the hood
you know so instead of taking these kids
and you know sort of training them to be
i don't say computer programmers
and trying to export them to work in the
west loop or downtown
the whole idea is to really try to build
industry at home
right in the cultural context that these
kids are growing up in
and that really just plays into this
idea of affirming the dignity of not
just
the kids we hire the kids to come to our
program but also the community right
because you know our farms are very
visible
they're residential neighborhoods you
know for those who aren't familiar with
chicago
chicago has tens of thousands of vacant
lots most of them are concentrated
in black communities on the south and
west sides of the city so you know it's
uncommon for you to be
driving on the residential block and
there's like you know six seven vacant
lots
on that block there's like a few
abandoned buildings right and you know
no one really wants to live like that
so we come in and we take over like
these vacant lots like and you know
there's these beautiful flowers in the
summer
it just helps bring like a sense of
community pride and beauty back to the
community
and then you sell the flowers to whoever
wants them
yeah so we're a social enterprise yes so
our model is basically we grow our own
flowers
and then you know we have our own
in-house flower shop called southside
blooms
and then we sell our flowers direct to
consumer through our website delivery
anywhere in the chicagoland area
it's fantastic and so the kids who go
through your program
now i understand what you talk about eco
house it's a double entendre
it's not the eco of the being ecological
and self-sustaining and off the grid
it's not the ecological
of a flower and the life of a plant
you're creating a new ecosystem
in the neighborhood exactly yes that's
correct
yes so now walk me through this
ecosystem so a kid goes through your
program
learns the dignity of work and sees the
joy
of teamwork creates new family then what
yeah so in terms of the ecosystem so
first you have to understand
the existing ecosystem because we're
really trying to do is displace
an inferior ecosystem right so the
current ecosystem is you kind of have a
kid
maybe grow up in a very rough situation
single mom household
for whatever reason they find themselves
being drawn to the street because like
street gangs
operate as families for a lot of the
youth that we work with
you know you be a corner boy you're
making money i mean you know a little
bit of money you know sort of dealing
drugs that kind of deal so that's like
the current ecosystem though current
way things work so with eco house
essentially
we try to compete with that by doing a
lot of the same things that you see
gangs do
just trying to redirect them to a more
positive conclusion right
good old-fashioned capitalism go to
fashion competition
you have a choice over there or you
might have a better choice over here
you're just offering an alternative
right that's very accurate you know
it is it is like a inverted sense of
capitalism you know what i mean
it's community capitalism
[Laughter]
well yeah i mean it's true like our
biggest competition equal house of the
game that's who we're competing against
it's not other flower shops it's not
other non-profits it's the street gangs
right
so we basically like looked at like okay
well what's appealing
in that ecosystem in that sort of sub
world or that subculture
and how can we basically recreate that
on our farms
eagle house also started out of you know
my house so
it's very community oriented you know so
if you were to come to eco house
you know like you'll see like kids
though they're around my personal kids
you know my wife loves to make meals for
them
it's a very family community-centric
atmosphere it's not like this sense
where hey you gotta work
nine to five and all we care about you
is from a vocational standpoint
no it's a more holistic we care about
you
as your family as you're you know and
we're still your employer of course
there's rules
i mean gangs have rules too but there's
this idea that you know you're more
than just you know a widget in a large
machine right
and then you know like similar to the
gangs like we're right here in the block
so our farms are right in the community
so there's kids who
literally live across the street from
where they work they get up
roll out bed at like 9 55 a.m they got
to be at work at 10
and they're right there
just like any other job
these are still like 19 20 year olds you
know
some things some things never change and
the other thing too is like they get a
lot of chances like we tell them on day
one like hey our goal
isn't to get rid of hey you're not
performing so you're fired and we're
forever done with you
so a lot of our kids like even if you're
underperforming reduced
hours you're not being scheduled as
often you know maybe get demoted to
our k through uh 12 youth program
um for a while you know or we try to
find some other resources to help you
out
because as you can imagine like a lot of
these kids are coming from some very
you know traumatic situations so there's
a lot of trauma that we have to work
through
with a lot of these young adults but the
whole idea is like they understand that
hey this is a place that can come to you
for help to make money
to be a part of my community to kind of
open up and talk about my problems
it operates similar to gangs because
that's the kind of stuff that happens in
the game
what is your success rate not
financially
not as a business but what is the
success you have that the people who go
through your program
stay with it that they don't go back to
the competition they don't go back to
the gang at this point i would say we're
probably
around 70 to 75 percent you know
of like retention and it's improved over
the years
so essentially what well basically what
we found is like
the more we can develop and refine
the business aspect of our organization
the better
of a draw it is for the kids we're
working with yeah which is part of the
reason why we are putting so much time
and energy and
resources into selling our flowers right
because ultimately like that's the hook
it's the same thing for the gangs right
you have become that unknown generous
spirit in the lives of these
boys and girls these young men and women
you have become the unknown team member
i think in some way shape or form you're
teaching them faith
i never thought about it like that hold
up i'm just digesting what you just said
um but yeah that's there's there's a lot
of truth to that
yeah there are people who who didn't
realize they had choice
they didn't realize there was another
path other than the fiction that they
were following
and through an uncommon act of
generosity from
an ostensible stranger they find
themselves with more choice and more
opportunity than they realized they had
which is exactly your story
yes i mean the reason i'm kind of
pausing is because it's kind of like
hitting home a little bit
of like oh wow like in a weird sort of
way
me going through all those trials and
going through like my own story
to get to this point was so that i could
do what i'm doing today you know i never
really thought about that it's almost
like you know you had to kind of go
through this
rough road and experience say all this
uncommon generosity
for you to then become generous yourself
in a weird way
and so now it's just like coming full
circle i just never really like
connected it
like that before and it's emotional
yeah i hope that's the impact i'm having
on these kids you know the way
people who kind of come into my life as
strategic points and really helped me
out
you know willing to give me a chance
when i didn't deserve a chance yeah i i
hope that's how they feel
and maybe that is how they feel they
keep coming back yeah it's very humbling
to think about that
have you sort of seen you know in your
sort of development
you know both personal uh professional
where there's been
a team of strangers that have helped you
out along your path
100 of course i struggle to take credit
for my own
career because i think that's madness
clearly i played a part
but only a small part the people who
many of whom i didn't know who heard me
or read my stuff and shared it with
someone gave it to someone invited me
back
i was not a part of any of those
conversations without a doubt
people who gave me opportunity out of
the blue people who gave me
constructive advice when i didn't want
to hear it
and no one else was giving it to me
there were tons of strangers some of
whom i've become friends with
by the way those friendships are really
deep loving friendships
because the thing that connected us was
an act of generosity
when we were strangers right so let me
sum up what i think i've
learned today and first of all i have to
say this you are magical and you have a
contagious laugh
you are just magic and you have taught
me
so much today i have learned
about the fact that life is uncertain
any certainty we think we have
some predestined path based on where
we're from or the
life we're supposed to live is entirely
a work of fiction
and to choose a path of conviction
to choose a path of passion has as much
uncertainty
as the fiction that we thought we were
on it was a false
sense of certainty and so why not choose
the path of passion and conviction
i've learned from you that life is not a
solo sport
and the team is a large group of people
many of whom we don't even know who our
team is
who's on our team and i find that
actually very relaxing actually very
calming to be honest
this belief that my team is there even
if i can't see them it actually makes me
feel a lot safer that i'm not doing this
alone
and the more we put ourselves out there
the team will show up but if we hide
the team doesn't know where we are right
you went to church
as opposed to staying in the basement
yes you showed up
you gave the team the opportunity to
serve you
and the other thing i learned is how
funny life is how much of an ecosystem
our lives are
you know you have all these definitions
of ecosystem
and what you're doing now is basically
your origin story
you know you were a seed now you've
grown and now you're replanting the
exact seeds that you grew from
and by the way that should be for all of
us
yes yes 100 and if we all keep planting
the seeds that we came from
before you know it we're living in a
beautiful garden
filled with color and bees and birds
and life is bright and colorful and
beautiful
if we all just remember to keep planting
our seeds and not
eating our seed and getting depressed
and on that note
thanks so much for taking the time i
can't tell you how grateful i am
oh yeah totally yeah i appreciate you a
lot simon so fun
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you